Welcome to the Man of Recaps, this
is the complete Transformers recap
before Rise of the Beasts. In the first
Transformers, Shia LaBeouf is Sam Witwicky,
a normal teenage boy whose dad is taking
him out to buy his first car. He picks
out this old yellow Camaro that
is “more than meets the eye.”
Now that Sam has a car, he’s able to give
a ride home to the hot girl from school,
Mikaela, played by Megan Fox, whose role in
this film caused a generation of boys to hit
puberty. But meanwhile, the Earth is being
invaded by transforming vehicles that are
alien robots in disguise. Turns out Sam's great
grandfather was an explorer, Archibald Witwicky,
who went to the North Pole and found one of
these transformers that crashed years ago.
It blasted his glasses with important
information, and now that Sam put them up on eBay,
the Decepticons are coming after him. But
luckily his new car is a transformer too,
here to protect him. His name is Bumblebee,
and his voice thing’s broken so he can't talk,
but he communicates in a fun way using
clips from the radio. Now bumblebee calls
in his good Transformer friends, the Autobots.
Their leader transforms into the semi-truck with a
blue and red flames paint job, it is Optimus
Prime. He explains they're from the planet
Cybertron, where there was a big civil war between
the good Autobots and the evil Decepticons,
led by Megatron. They go back to Sam's house
to get the glasses before the Decepticons,
but now they're interrupted by the government.
It's the super secret Sector Seven, who monitors
alien life here, led by the funny guy, Agent
Simmons. They have Megatron’s frozen body,
as well as the All Spark, that could instill life
into machines to make new transformers. But oh no,
they led the Decepticons right to it.
They wake up Megatron, who's in a real
bad mood and oh, it's a big chase, oh yeah!
Meanwhile, half the movie followed military
guy and his squad fighting Decepticons in the
desert. Another half of the movie follows a CIA
analyst who's inexplicably an Australian model.
She got help from her friend who was playing
Dance Dance Revolution at his grandma's house
- there's a lot going on in these movies.
But it all comes together for the final battle.
Transformers transforming, explosions everywhere,
Michael Bay going nuts! But they got to keep
the All Spark away from Megatron because he
wants to use it to turn the earth into New
Cybertron. So while the Transformers are
having their big robot fight, Sam Witwicky’s
running around with the plot thing. Optimus
and Megatron have their final fight, but
it looks like Megatron is going to win.
So Optimus wants to put the All Spark in his
chest, which will kill him but destroy the
cube. But Sam's like, what if I shoved the cube
into Megatron’s chest instead? And that works,
destroys the cube, kills megatron. Yeah,
good thinking kid. So the earth is saved,
Sam and Mikaela have a sunset make out. Then
Optimus Prime gives an inspiring speech,
and it is the iconic Linkin Park credits song.
Number two is Transformers Revenge of the Fallen.
Sam Witwicky is going off to college, but in
his pocket he finds a little piece of the All
Spark that blasts his mind with alien info. The
Decepticons steal another piece of the All Spark,
and putting the All Spark in Megatron’s
chest killed him, but putting it in
again brings him back to life.
Mikaela comes to visit Sam to find
him in a compromising position, but it's
even worse than it looks because it's a
transformer. So Megatron grabs him to get the
info in his head, but his car Bumblebee busts
in to save him. Optimus Prime comes too,
but oh no, it was a trap, they outnumbered
him. And now Megatron kills Optimus Prime.
Turns out Megatron has a boss, another Prime
called The Fallen. And now with Optimus out
of the way, he's able to come down to Earth
and get his revenge, so it is the Revenge of the
Fallen. Now the government is anti-Transformer,
so Sam gets help from Agent Simmons, who was fired
from Sector Seven and is now working in a deli.
But he still is the Transformers expert, who
has info that they've been here longer than
we thought. They break into the Air and Space
Museum to find this old Transformer who somehow
teleports them to Egypt, because all nine Primes
were here in ancient times to hide the special
plot thing that oh, disintegrates. Then a bunch
of construction decepticons all merge together
into one giant sucking monster, because turns
out, the pyramids? Built by Transformers.
Now military guy rolls up with the cavalry and
it's a big final fight in Egypt. Explosions
everywhere, CGI transforming, Sam's parents are
here for some reason. While the Transformers have
their big robot battle, Shia LaBeouf runs around
with the plot thing. He has a vision where the
ancient Primes deem him worthy, so it un-dissolves
the thing and he shoves it into Optimus’ chest,
and Optimus Prime is back to life!
But The Fallen busts in and grabs it
before anyone can react, and he's going to turn
on the pyramid thing that would turn the Earth
into New Cybertron. But now Optimus merges with
old plane guy and gets wings, flies up there,
blows it up, kills the fallen, the day is
saved. Megatron retreats to fight another day,
Sam and Mikeala have a sunset make out.
Then Optimus Prime gives an inspiring speech,
and the credits hit us with that other Linkin
Park song. Number three is Transformers Dark
of the Moon. Sam Witwicky is happily dating not
Megan Fox? Yes after everything Sam and Mikaela
went through, they write her off with one line
and Sam moved on immediately. Sam starts working
for John Malkovich, but his coworker Ken
Jeong, accosts him in the bathroom with
Transformers conspiracy theories that Decepticons
are assassinating people for some big cover up.
Sam tries to warn the government, but they're
like, “Get out of here, kid. We got this
covered.” The Autobots have been working with the
government, they got their own super secret team,
but now they discover a link to another historical
event: the moon landing? Yeah, Transformers. And
in that crashed ship is Optimus’ old boss. They
bring him back to life, it’s Sentinel Prime.
But Sam calls up his old friend Agent Simmons, and
together they discover the Decepticons’ secret:
Sentinel Prime switched sides, oh, he's
a Decepticon now! He uses the teleporting
things to open a portal on the moon where
a secret Decepticon army was waiting,
and it's a full on invasion, the earth can't stop
it. The Decepticons say they'll leave Earth alone
if the humans exile the Autobots.
Optimus Prime says goodbye and oh, no,
the Autobots are immediately blown up. And of
course the Decepticons lied, now without the
Autobots to stand in their way they're going to
teleport Cybertron here and use Earth to rebuild
it. But now what's this, the Autobots are still
alive! Yeah, they saw that coming and faked their
deaths. So it's the final battle in Chicago, and
it's a full hour of insane CGI action, explosions
everywhere, I have no idea what’s happening.
Military guy shows up with the cavalry, they
jump out the plane wing suits, wow! And while
the Transformers have their big robot fight,
Shia LeBeouf is running around with the plot thing
- and he's gotten really good at running. Sam's
girlfriend's boss is the bad guy working with the
Decepticons, so Sam tracks him down, breaks the
thing and shuts it off, Cybertron destroyed!
Optimus and Sentinel have their final Prime fight,
and it looks like Sentinel is going to win. But
Megatron doesn't like that Sentinel would be his
boss, so he busts in to take him out. So it's the
final battle, Megatron versus Optimus, and Optimus
just fully kills him this time. So the world is
saved, Sam and this new girl have a sunset make
out. And Optimus Prime gives an epic speech as
they blast us with that other Linkin Park song.
Number four is Transformers Age of
Extinction. Shia LaBeouf left the movies too,
our new main human is Mark Wahlberg. His
name is Cade Yeagar, and he's an inventor,
which his daughter points out is not a real
job. But one day he's fixing up this old truck,
and wouldn't you know it, It's Optimus Prime.
After Chicago the government is very anti
transformer, there's a new secret task force
led by Kelsey Grammer, who's hunting down all
Transformers, Decepticons and Autobots.
So pretty soon they track Optimus down,
Yeager's house explodes. They get a ride out of
there from his daughter's secret boyfriend, who,
even though they're in Texas, is inexplicably
Irish. Cade's funny best friend is T.J. Miller,
and on the way out, oh, he's exploded.
So Optimus regroups with our new cast of Autobots:
a samurai, a British gangster, and a guy still
fighting in Vietnam. Elsewhere, Stanley Tucci
is a tech CEO who's found the Transformium
that Transformers are made of and has learned
how to control it. He's building new manmade
transformers, but they're using Megatron’s old
brain, so he accidentally created new Megatron.
Now a bounty hunter robot shows up with a canon
for a face, blows up Optimus. He's bringing him
back to Cybertron because the “creators” want him.
But Yeager and friends rescue Optimus,
on their way out they destroy Chicago,
again. But now they have a bigger problem because
the deal that guy made with Kelsey Grammer was to
give him a “Seed” to get lots of Transformium.
Unfortunately, using it would destroy the planet,
and in fact it's happened once before. The
meteor that killed the dinosaurs? Turns out,
Transformers. Megatron of course wants this to
happen, to turn Earth into New Cybertron. He
wakes up all these manmade transformers and turns
them into his new Decepticon army. But Optimus
gets some reinforcements too, from the really
old transformers that turn into dinosaurs!
So it's the epic final battle, Transformers
transforming, explosions everywhere, I have
no idea what's happening. The American military
doesn't show up because this takes place in Hong
Kong. While the Transformers have their big robot
fight, it's up to our humans to run around with
the plot thing. Megatron retreats to fight
another day, Kelsey Grammer does not though,
he gets exploded. But now Cannon Face
finally realizes Optimus escaped,
but with help from Bumblebee, and Mark Wahlberg,
in the end Optimus takes this guy out.
So once again the earth is saved, Cade’s daughter
and boyfriend have a sunset make out, and Optimus
Prime blasts into space. He's got to go back
to Cybertron to find out who this mysterious
creator is. And as he gives an epic speech, the
credits hit us with, not Linkin Park, but Imagine
Dragons, which I guess is kind of close.
Number five is Transformers The Last Knight.
The government again is very anti Transformers, so
Cade Yeager is a fugitive living in the junkyard
with his Autobot friends. His daughter and her
boyfriend are not in this movie, his new sidekicks
are funny science guy and spunky orphan kid. So
the government’s hunting all transformers down,
but Cade Yeager's trying to save them.
He finds this one who crashed here and
gives him a mysterious medallion. But now
Megatron busts in, he wants that medallion,
so they have a big fight. But it's interrupted by
a random butler transformer who flies Yeager over
to England to meet with Anthony Hopkins. He's the
last living member of the Witwiccans, the secret
society that knows about Transformers.
Yeah, as we've seen, basically every big
moment in human history has been Transformers,
including mythology like King Arthur. Knights
of the Round Table? Yeah, Transformers. The
hot girl in this movie is Vivienne Wembley,
professor of King Arthur stuff. Anthony Hopkins
kidnaps her too, because she's the last living
descendant of Merlin and the only one who
can use his Magic Transformer staff.
Long story short, they steal a submarine, go to
the bottom of the ocean to find Merlin's tomb and
get the staff. But who's this busting in? It's
Optimus Prime, acting like a villain here to
take that staff. Yeah he flew to Cybertron to find
his creator, who, turns out, is this witch robot
Quintessa that instantly possessed him. So it's
up to Bumblebee to fight his friend Optimus.
And he eventually un-brainwashes him when he
speaks with his real voice. They don't even
explain how he can talk now, which is especially
weird because they had a whole scene earlier
where they tried to fix his voice and decided
they couldn't. So Optimus is un-brainwashed,
but the Knights the Round Table bots are still
attacking him because he stole the staff.
So Mark Wahlberg's got to use his new
medallion to woah, summon Excalibur!
Just then Megatron busts in and steals the staff
before anyone can react. He gives it to Quintessa,
whose evil master plan is the same as it's
always been: she brings Cybertron here and
is gonna suck up Earth's energy to rebuild it.
Agent Simmons comes back to explain, why Earth?
Turns out Earth and Cybertron are connected,
in fact, Earth’s real name is Unicron.
So they go to Stonehenge, which was also built
by Transformers, and Anthony Hopkins tries to
1v1 Megatron, which doesn't work, he blows up. So
it's the final battle on the pieces of Cybertron,
explosions everywhere, CGI robots, I have
no idea what's going on. Military guy rolls
up with the cavalry, we keep cutting
to Tony Hale, who's a scientist.
Then Cade and Vivienne have a sunset make out,
while the Transformers are doing their big robot
battle, the humans are running around to do
the plot thing. Megatron retreats to fight
another day, but Bumblebee blasts Quintessa, so
Vivienne gets the staff, and the world is saved,
once again. Except for like all the
places that got totally destroyed.
And also there's these giant metal horns
that appeared and were never explained, and
a mysterious woman is going to do something with
them, what?! That’s Quintessa in disguise. And as
Optimus Prime gives an epic speech, it's really
disappointing, not even close to Linkin Park.
And that brings us to Bumblebee. It's the spin
off prequel about how Bumblebee came to Earth in
the 1980s, and it is a totally different type of
movie, less big action blockbuster, more Disney
Channel original. So Bumblebee was fighting in the
war on Cybertron when Optimus was like “Yo, you
need to escape to Earth to get a foothold there.”
So Bumblebee first comes to Earth in the 1980s,
which contradicts what we learned in The Last
Knight about how he fought in World War Two.
But soon a Decepticon catches up with him,
interrogates him for information, but Bumblebee
is not talking. And so, as punishment, this is
where it happens, ah, he destroys Bumblebee’s
voice. Bumblebee does beat this guy, but he's
badly damaged, so he finds a nice yellow Bug
and shuts down. Our human in this movie is Hailee
Steinfeld as Charlie Watson, whose character trait
is, she really wants a car. At the junkyard she
finds this old yellow Beetle, takes it home to
fix it up and whoa, my car's an alien!
She and Bumblebee become fast friends,
in fact she's the one who names him Bumblebee.
And she's the one that helps him figure out
that he can talk using the radio. So they're
cruising around getting up to shenanigans,
but John Cena is the Sector Seven agent here
to hunt him down, and also a couple more
Decepticons are here to destroy the world.
So in the end, Bumblebee’s having a robot fight
while Charlie's running around doing the plot
thing. But what's this, Bumblebee is going to
drown! Luckily, her backstory is that she was,
like, a really good diver, until her dad died, now
she doesn't dive anymore. But now she overcomes
her fear and dives in there to save his life.
Although, of course, he's a robot that doesn't
breathe air, and I mean, in the last movie he rode
a submarine to the bottom of the ocean. Anyway,
John Cena accepts that Bumblebee’s a good guy now,
but the government’s still hunting him,
so they have to say goodbye. He finds
a cool old Camaro to be his new disguise,
to eventually be found by Sam Witwicky.
So there you have it, The complete
Transformers recap before Rise of the Beasts!
If you like this recap, hit that subscribe button
for more of the best recaps of TV and movies.